the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so today I will talk about mostly
fees which is an interesting and
somewhat contentious issue in Bitcoin
and all these other systems so scheduled
for today problem set three description
we'll talk about fees these unknowable
acronyms child pays for parent and
replaced by fee and then talk a little
bit about long term incentives in
Bitcoin and how that relates to fees
okay so the problem set three is to grab
UT exos hopefully it's fun you're gonna
be making transactions on the real
bitcoin test network so one of the parts
of it that hopefully it's not too hard
is you know download and install Bitcoin
D so put a link the current most
up-to-date version is 0.16 point zero I
believe the next version will just be
called 17 because a lot of the
developers are like this is annoying
it's always starting with a zero because
like 0.1 0.2 0.3 and they're like well
at some point should we get to version 1
and they're like well everyone's gonna
think version 1 means it's like better
let's just call the next version 17
instead of 0.17 so download that and
then sync up to test net if you just run
it by default it will sync up to the
main network which will download
something like 170 gigabytes you you
don't want that and the homework
assignment cannot be completed on the
main network or yeah there's no free
money I haven't put any free money on
the main network however on the test
network it'll work
and it's about 11 gigabytes of download
so I think most people on your laptop
probably have 11 gigs free it's doable
and it's kind of fun to see how it works
so if you don't have access to 11 gigs I
mean you can probably get an Athena node
to do it it's it's not too big you can
run like a tiny little node with not
much RAM not much space and it'll work
you can also sync up on a Raspberry Pi
it just takes a little longer so I don't
think it'll be too hard to do you can
probably get around like sort of the
goal of the assignment is to check out
the you know actual Bitcoin D and
Bitcoin CLI you can use a block Explorer
if you want I'm not gonna say that's
cheating but it's also not as fun so the
block explorers websites will help you
find a lot of things because they have
different databases and different
indexes so you can sort of search
through things it's more fun if you
write it yourself but if you try this
okay that works too yeah so hopefully
you get familiar with the bitcoin CLI if
you want to do your own scripting with
Bitcoin you can use anything you want
so Bitcoin CLI is a command-line utility
that will you know let you interact with
the Bitcoin node so for example that's
readable right so if I want to get peer
info I want to see this is a computer
down on the first floor running Bitcoin
main net I want to see ok who's
connected to me and then it'll tell me
you know it returns JSON and it tells me
all about the people I'm connected to if
I want to say get wallet info it'll tell
me I don't have any money
things like that so you can you can and
then there's like help it's it's weird
and it's not super well documented it's
fairly well documented in this stuff
there's also like tons of undocumented
hidden RPC calls that are like
deprecated or new or programmers put in
they don't want people to use them they
only want to use them for themselves so
it's it's kind of a mess but it's fun to
see like exactly how this software works
so hopefully you can try that out yeah
and I will add more UTX OS to grab in
the next few days so that won't be fine
you could if you wanted to be a jerk
just steal all the money and then no-one
else can do it but like please don't do
that I mean this is not as adversarial a
setting has actual Bitcoin if someone
does it I'll be like ok fine and I'll
just like reseed the place but so
hopefully we don't have too many trolls
trying to prevent everyone from having
fun with this Assange that said there is
an aspect some of them are you know the
one I put in the assignment last night
there's five outputs that you can grab
you know one of the one of the like sort
of hints there's only five output so the
first five people to grab it get the
coins so there is a little bit of like
timing
any questions cool okay yeah so if you
have questions about it office hours
tomorrow also IRC okay so today's main
topic transaction fees so we described
earlier that the transaction fee is just
the difference between the sum of the
input amounts and output amounts what's
interesting is it's implicit so if you
actually look at a transaction you can't
tell what the fees are you have to look
at its ancestors to tell what the fees
are so for example if you want to go
through here and how am I gonna do this
geez if I want to say okay what's the
most what's the most current block okay
yep block chain info okay so the most
current block is this and then I can say
okay get block I just say get block yep
I want to get that block okay there's
all the transactions in this block I can
do get block verbose true and it'll give
me all the transaction data but instead
I can just pick one of these
transactions and say get raw transaction
get that thing oh here's another weird
thing you have to push so it'll just
give you hacks which is not very useful
unless you somehow can read hexadecimal
and then in the actual thing it says
like examples true did they change it
you used to have to do one at the end
yeah but true works to know true you
used to not work if you said true and
you had to put the number one instead of
true there's a lot of weird bugs in
Bitcoin that have been there for years
and I guess they fix that one the most
egregious is probably the multi-sig bug
where when you're spending from a
multi-sig output you have to push a zero
byte on to the stack first or else it
doesn't work it was just a bug Satoshi
had and now it's consensus critical and
like people joke about like oh we also
have to put a zero byte in whatever new
RPC we create because there's just like
bugs anyway so for example this
transaction that I just
brought up its got and this is how they
look uh here's the TX ID its 370 bytes
it's got this lock time which you I
should mention that I'm guessing this
community section was created by a
Bitcoin core wallet not a different
wallet because that's a hint it's got
one input no two inputs ok so there's
you know inputs are specified this TX ID
input this TX ID input two inputs and
one output of value zero zero zero four
five zero zero we can't tell what the
fee is from this no no sorry two outputs
here the two of us so we can tell these
two outputs however we don't know what
the fees are we know the total outputs
amounts but the inputs amount input
amounts are not encoded in the
transaction itself in order to figure
that out we'd have to go to this
transaction and see what the out zeroes
output amount is which we can do and
it's oh oh five - you know so we can add
it up that way but it's it's not written
directly which is a little weird and the
idea of the fee is whoever minds that
block that includes that transaction
gets the fee right so the sum of all the
inputs and outputs within a block do add
up like modulo the new coins that are
created but you know what long term when
there's no coins being created when
they've all been created you can say
okay we can look at a block add up all
the inputs spent in this in all the
transactions in the block add up all the
outputs created in all the transactions
in the block and those should equal
otherwise it's invalid well they don't
have to equal you're always allowed to
destroy coins right so if you if the
miner says hey there's all these fees
that can be paid to me and I just don't
grab them you can do that so it's you
know it less than or equals operator
that it's the check and people have
destroyed coins usually inadvertently
there was one in January where there was
a block that just had a zero output for
minor reward so all whatever 1314 coins
were just destroyed yet it seems like a
bug
so you can so that's how you know fees
work what's interesting is you don't
know who you're paying when you create
the fee right you you signed sort of
okay here's my transaction I sign it off
whoever confirms this transaction gets
five bucks or whatever and you throw it
out there so it's kind of interesting
there could be legal I've heard there's
like legal questions like well what if
one of the minors is in Iran now you're
paying someone in Iran are you in
trouble for that you know you can't tell
who's gonna mine it beforehand okay
yeah and generally we talk about fee
rates or sort of a specific you know fee
per byte and it's expressed in satoshis
per byte and once the Toshi being the
minimum possible bitcoin amount which is
three zeros yeah so seven zero so
there's eight digits in bitcoins so and
you usually keep that so like yeah you
Pat it out right so even even in
something where it's zero point zero one
three four they put the extra four
zeroes in the actual code
this is just a 64-bit signed integer and
there is no decimal point right so so
it's sort of a UI thing to put a decimal
point in so that people can think of
like oh that's two bitcoins or that's
half a Bitcoin but really the code only
deals with the satoshis and the decimal
point is purely UI layer which can be
confusing and sometimes when you're
dealing with JSON and when you're
dealing with like different programs
tossing numbers around you can get a
factor of 100 million off sometimes it's
a big enough factor that usually it's
pretty obvious so from a miners point of
view they want to prioritize based on
the TX size and the fee rate because
space is limited right so one of the
other rules that's probably one of the
most controversial and like argued about
rules in Bitcoin was 1 megabyte block
size limit so the idea is okay you can
put all these transactions and block
but the total block when serialized
including the headers and everything
needs to be 1 million bytes or less
which is now not quite true because
there's ways around that but there's
still a hard limit of 4 megabytes today
what's also interesting is it's totally
unrelated to the amount of coins being
transferred right so in that sense the
fee is flat right whether you're sending
a hundred bitcoins or one Bitcoin or a
millionth of a Bitcoin the miner doesn't
really care it's just how you know it's
just based on space you're paying for
your data usage of the network and your
actual sort of monetary value
transferring is unrelated to that to
some extent you've later on you might
think well miners might try to charge
people sending more money more because
you know there it more able to pay but
so far we haven't seen anything like
that it's mostly just the miners looking
at you know I've got a megabyte of size
to parcel out to people I'm gonna try to
you know pack that in is at higher rate
as I can and whether someone's paying a
little bit or a lot you know whenever
someone's moving a little bit or a lot
the miners don't care any questions
about these things I'm gonna do this
well and if you assume that the block is
valid right so so okay the first the
first transaction is always the coinbase
transaction that's little so I'm gonna
do get raw transaction get this one and
yeah sighs coinbase
right so coinbase is arbitrary data
you've got a sequence number there is no
witness here okay anyway oh yeah there
is witness okay so this block is well
two blocks have come out since I first
looked in it because there's no two
confirmations
this is segment related which I think
I'm going to talk about Monday so that's
sort of this weird opportune thing this
is the the actual coin based payout that
the minor is getting and it's 12
sorry twelve point seven nine you know
so it's so he got you know almost point
four extra coins in fees which is what
like four thousand dollars you know
pretty good
it was super high a few months ago but
um so so it all gets aggregated right
this is this is 12.5 comes out of
nowhere 12.5 is the new coins being
generated and then the you know 0.39
eight is the sum of all the fees in that
block well you can look you have to look
at all the transactions right so if you
look at a transaction it doesn't say in
the transaction itself you'd have to
look at a transaction look up its inputs
see what you know the sum of all the
inputs and then you know subtract and
say okay I can calculate the fee for
this transaction calculate the fee for
all these different transactions add it
all up it should equal and it does
exactly equal you know 0.39 eight put it
up so it's for the computer it's pretty
quick right but yeah it is a little bit
weird accounting to try to add it all up
yourself okay any other questions about
fee stuff about this yes
yes but I'm not sure I put it that way
it's the miners construct the block to
mine right so so in the case of your get
block head - 30 I don't want to show all
of the but you know this is okay the
miner mind this block here's the size
weight height version Merkel route all
these transactions that get included are
produced by the miner so the miner sort
of aggregates the transactions
themselves and then decides to mind so I
think I talked about that in the next
yeah
so that yeah okay I'll just I'll talk
about that in the next life so basically
the fee rate is set by the transaction
signer right when you're creating a
transaction okay I want to send one
Bitcoin I will spend you know 500
Satoshi's my transactions about 250
bytes okay that's a to satoshis per byte
fee right you create you know you choose
your fee right sign the way you
increment and decrement your fee rate is
to say okay I've got some change output
I'm going to increase or decrease that
change output him out if someone's
saying hey pay me one coin I can't
really change their amount and say like
oh sorry man there was a high fee he
didn't get a bit Bitcoin it's sort of
the and that's sort of a cultural that's
not a software thing that's just a if
someone says pay me a coin you need to
pay the coin it's generally the sender
who's covering the fee which is
different than in credit cards right in
credit cards it says ten bucks I swipe
my card I get charged ten bucks and the
merchant is the one absorbing the fee
and I don't even know what the fee is
there's there's actually contractual law
that I not allowed to hear what the fee
is you know the merchant can't tell me
it's things like that but in general in
Bitcoin that this fee is set by the
sender the transactions however chosen
by the miners so the idea is you you
create your transaction set your feet
throw it out there everyone sort of
broadcasts it to everyone else and the
miner then looks at all these fees you
know looks at all these transactions and
chooses the best ones right it's
essentially an auction
where you're bidding for a space in a
future block that has not yet been
created so the simplest minor side
algorithm is take the mempool sort the
mental transactions by their fee rate
choose the top megabyte put them all in
order compute a merkel root from that
you know all those transaction IDs and
then mine it right so the the yeah I
explained the merkel root stuff right so
you know pick your gonna pick a couple
thousand five thousand maybe
transactions sort of by fee right put
them all in a row you know hash it a
bunch of times and then just that eighty
byte header you keep mining however this
keeps changing this member will changes
every second right there's new
transactions coming up multiple times a
second and so you're gonna recompute
that every second probably and say oh
this new this new transaction came out
oh the fees really low ignore it right
that's that that doesn't meet my my
threshold versus new transaction comes
out oh it's got a really high fever
eight okay sort of re you know put it in
near the top and push out one or two
transactions at the bottom and now I'm
mining a block that it'll have slightly
higher fees so this is sort of a
real-time process where this is
constantly changing the mining is even
faster so you're going to mine trillions
and trillions of attempts for each
specific merkel route but the merkel
routes are also going to change multiple
times a second just the nuts is gonna
change yes
so you know it's in the memo you know it
hasn't been configured
that it has not been confirmed in a
block already right but it may be the
case that someone just came out over the
block a few seconds ago and you haven't
seen it and then you are mining a sale
transaction the thing is whether the
transactions tale or not even if you
mine if you mine a block and it's got a
completely different set of transactions
than the block you were unaware of you
still lose out right because you're
you're pointing so okay this comes out
but you're not aware of it yet and you
mind this even if even if they have a
completely disjoint set of transactions
it doesn't matter because you're still
pointing me the same parent block
so you're still now have a you know two
blocks at the same height
you might win right if you if this
happens hey maybe this one gets built
upon generally miners pick the first
seen block to build off of but that's
you know you could change that you you
could and you can't really verify that
that's the case so yeah it is possible
you're mining transactions that have
already been included in the block that
you're not aware of yes
different mining you could so so in
practice probably yes but on a very
small time scale right so what what
you'll have is will get block template
you'll have it's may sit like will
network latency so you'll have let's say
a bunch of different warehouses that all
have a you know thousands and thousands
of these mining chips and they will
connect in you know and they'll pull
every second or so and get the current
transaction list of mine and that will
get updated every second and so there
may be sort of lags and like between
different warehouses between different
machines that are mining slightly
different sets of transactions but
generally they're gonna be synchronous
over the skate time scale of a few
seconds they're all going to be
synchronized but and and yeah they're
gonna be updated pretty quickly because
every time a new transaction comes in
that's potentially more fees that you
can get so you want to push that out and
update it if you you know let's say a
transaction comes in that's got a nice
five-dollar fee and you can push out
some four dollar fee transactions that's
an extra book and if you don't get it in
time and mine a block anyway hey you
still mind a block but that five dollar
fee transaction now goes to the next
person Mining on the block so you you
want to you know pretty you want to
minimize your latency so that you get
things as quickly as possible but there
will be some skew if you have if you
have a wait wait stay okay wait
still transactions you know a
transaction that's already been in a
block it just invalidates the whole
thing if you have if you have a
transaction here that was already
confirmed here this blocks invalid and
no one will you know they'll just drop
it so it's not yeah stale transaction
isn't really a term it's still block is
if you know this is a stale block is
like well someone made it but it got
orphaned out and no one's using it okay
yeah
worse you lose all you know you lose
everything
if you include so if you know there's
transaction a in here and you try to
include transaction a in here the block
itself is invalid even if it has valid
proof of work so you lose everything
so don't the thing is
in practice it's not a problem because
if you're you know you're pointing to
this block right so you must you must
have already seen it so it's really easy
to just say well don't include any of
the transactions in here
okay wait sometimes it's a little
complicated sometimes you see this block
and then you immediately want to start
mining the block on top of it but it's
you know a fraction of a second and you
haven't actually validated it and you
don't even know what's in it maybe you
only have the head the 80 byte header so
one optimization which is sort of bad in
a way but optimal for the miners is
build a block that's empty on top of it
you have you haven't even seen what
transactions are in this block you don't
even know if it's valid but it's
probably valid because most blocks are
and so what you do is he build on top of
it you point to it but since you don't
know what transactions are in it the
safest thing is just include no
transactions in your so there's no
overlap and if you know you what you
only do this for a fraction of a second
until you've figured out the transaction
list here and like subtracted although
you know removed all those from your set
that way but it saves you maybe you know
tenth of a second xx you know whatever
it is which over time statistically you
could be mining in that tenth of a
second right you don't want to you don't
want your chips to not be doing anything
productive for those fractions of a
second so that that does happen that is
not software that's in the normal
Bitcoin D but miners have have written
their own software to do that and so you
will occasionally see completely empty
blocks with just a coinbase transaction
and they're almost always very soon
after the previous block right well you
see one that comes out at you know 10 30
and 27 seconds 10 30 and 29 seconds and
it's empty so that is that does happen
and that can that could work although
what was it to you
ago that happened where minor mind a
block that was invalid another minor
mind a block here very quickly that was
empty
and then everyone started a bunch of
minor started building off of it because
they're like well this one looks valid
there's no transactions in it and they
mind like six or seven blocks in a row
and the whole thing was just invalid so
because they figured you know well the
stuff I'm building off of must be okay
so they lost some money there this makes
sense right so yeah sort the men pole by
fear a choose the top megabyte computer
Merkel wrote mine why is it not this
simple and I mean like on an algorithmic
way if you're just like yeah sort you
know choose fee rate sort you know quick
sort or whatever that's super quick and
then mine why is it actually complexity
wise not what is it and login for
quicksort it's definitely not any log n
for the optimal although a quicksort is
worst-case scenario and squared it right
so no it's way worse than N squared
anyway
any guesses on to why the algorithmic
complexity is this is actually quite a
bit worse no I'm saying even at any yeah
that that shouldn't changes it over time
but at any one state and say here's a
mempool find the optimal you know
finally transaction set to put into your
block
yeah that's that's still and squirt you
know and login right yeah just because
the lookup is slower that just that
doesn't change the oh yeah yeah so
there's dependencies right so the thing
is there may be a transaction you can't
just take all these transactions
independently and sort though there may
be a transaction with a very high fee
rate which depends on a transaction with
a very low fee rate right and so you
know it's spending an output that hasn't
yet been created so now it becomes it's
you know it's np-hard in practice the
heuristics are fine but it is like
pretty ugly in that you're like well
there's this this transaction has a very
low fee I'm not going to include it this
transaction that depends on it has a
high fee right now I have to take the
sort of mean of the two fee rates and
keep computing those things so it can
get quite complex in practice it's
usually okay you have some heuristics in
the code that sort of don't deal with
that also I think you have max there's
no hard rule but the algorithms that
mine usually have like a max depth of
like three or four transactions where
they say look if there's a chain of like
four dependent transactions I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna keep going down that
path right because you could potentially
have like enormous chains where you have
a hundred transactions each depending on
another and then the one at the very end
has a very high fee rate and you're
gonna have to like go through all this
so they limit their search to like four
or something like that oh sorry this
yeah so the TX dependencies make it kind
of hard
cheap transaction which allows an
expensive transaction to be confirmed we
call this child pays for parent right in
that you've got this sort of you know in
a graph you've got a child transaction
and it's essentially paying for the
parent transaction by having a higher
fee there is no there is no parent pays
for child right in that if you've got a
transaction with a high fee rate and
then a descendant transaction with the
low fee rate well you just take the
parent and you ignore the child right
and someone else in a later block can
grab that child transaction however you
know the dependency graph islem know if
you want in this child the parent has to
be
confirm first it actually has to be
confirmed earlier in the list of TX IDs
in the block right so it's not yeah so
like in this you know when you look at a
block the transactions are sequenced and
you know if this transaction can spend
that transaction but you you need to be
able to go in through linearly you know
update your UT Exocet at every row here
and it should be consistent yes oh okay
so in the there isn't really a threshold
it's just at any point you're like
looking and you're like well my minimum
fee here is thirty satoshis per byte you
know given the block I'm trying to mine
what's my lowest fee okay thirty
satoshis provide so if I see one with
less than that I know right away I can
ignore it but yeah it keeps changing
every time a new transaction comes in
that displaces an old one
you're now your minimum fee changes so
that's just sort of an easy way to look
there is also a real a threshold which I
believe most nodes now have it one
Satoshi per byte where if you're not
mining and someone gives you a
transaction which is less than one
Satoshi per byte fee rate you will
ignore it and not pass it on to your
peers that's sort of an anti-spam kind
of thing and it may be too high like
it's it's also not a consensus rule and
you can set it to whatever you want in
your config file and and nodes won't get
mad at you they won't ban you if you
send something low but so that's sort of
from the minor side from the miners
point of view you keep seeing all these
transactions you sort them you have to
deal with the sort of descendant
transactions but you try to get a good
block try to mine it and you don't
really care what people are doing you
just want to make a lot of money right
you just want to maximize for fees from
the person transacting on their side you
want to minimize fees right you don't to
pay these miners they already make
gazillions of dollars anyway from all
the new bitcoins they're generating
bunch of jerks so you set your fee to
one Satoshi per byte so you know it'll
be relayed you sign it you broadcast
easy right so what's the problem here
doesn't confirmed all the miners ignore
it this is actually a huge I would well
okay no probably the biggest sort of UI
problem in Bitcoin is that people have
for years and years lost all of their
coins due to theft or loss or whatever
that's that's the big one
but other than that this is the biggest
UI problem this is the biggest problem
it make point for users I made a
transaction it hasn't confirmed what the
heck and I sort of had on reddit you
know BTC fees WTF like why are BTC fees
so high you know there's constant people
complaining like what the heck why are
you kidding me treasurer says fifteen
fees I am I missing something you know
people get mad and then there's also I
made a transaction last week it hasn't
confirmed Bitcoin doesn't work the coin
sucks you know I hate this thing
so huge UI problem really poor user
experience a lot of it is also the
software is bad wallets
okay couple years ago wallets who would
always just set a zero fee
there weren't fees in 2012
you just didn't pay any 2013 right I
didn't I never paid fees it was awesome
because the there was this block size
limit of one megabyte but no one was
ever running up against that limit right
the miners would just say look I'm not
even gonna sort anything because there's
two hundred you know two hundred
kilobytes worth of transactions in the
mempool i just mined all of them right
whether the fees are zero whether these
are one Satoshi whatever whatever I can
get just mine at all now you've got this
constrained space and so you're
optimizing for you know the minor is but
years ago you weren't and so the wall
it's a lot of times they would either
you know have zero fee completely a
fixed fee per transaction which is also
really sub-optimally they just say okay
I'll pay 100 Satoshi's per transaction
some transactions have a lot of inputs
are much bigger so that's a highly
variable fee rate which the user can't
control or they'd have a fixed fee rate
where they just say I'm gonna set five
Satoshi's for a byte and that's the fee
rate in this wallet and you don't allow
the user to change it at all
that's also really suboptimal once the
fee you know once the fee market starts
changing and people start paying more
these these Wallet software will not
work or you can have the user to the fee
rate which seems great but users like I
don't know what you know you're using
Bitcoin do you what fee rate do you want
10 Satoshi to provide 20 40 70
what's the Satoshi what's a byte like I
don't you know this is not a great
problem to hand off to the user how do I
even determine this there are sites and
the sites aren't very good either
where was it yeah here is what used to
be 21 KO with all the Raspberry Pi guys
and then this is their fear a thing
which sort of it's really hard to
understand chart wait what does this
mean
unconfirmed transactions transaction
today what are these numbers I I still
don't really understand this site and at
the bottom it says fastest and cheapest
transaction fee is 50 Satoshi's per byte
shown in green at the top so I guess
this for this thing is huge over
estimate i think one Satoshi per byte is
probably okay today maybe five this is a
better site also complex where you can
say okay well here's the mempool size in
megabytes sorted by fee rate and you can
see that well at 8 o'clock mempool is
basically empty right at 8 o'clock you
can append 0 and it would have gotten
through but people are paying more now
and it's also kind of crazy to see that
some people are paying 200 Satoshi's per
byte even though generally over the
course of a few hours 0 satoshis per
byte will also confirm are they really
time sensitive probably not probably
their software is crummy
and their software just estimates 200 so
it's it's yeah it's it's like it's easy
ok it's easy to make fun of people be
like these guys are idiots it's actually
not that easy to estimate what fee you
should have issue a transaction with
it's also it's also sort of asymmetric
in a lot of exchanges someone says I
want to withdraw my 10 bitcoins right
I've you know I traded either
a lot of money withdraw click it doesn't
confirm for six hours the customer gets
super mad and starts calling you know
calling um
customer support whereas if the exchange
is like look we're just gonna issue all
our transactions with two hundred
Satoshi's per byte they always go
through the next block yeah we lose
money but like maybe we get the customer
to pay for big so I don't know of any
soft I've never seen any software that
does that I've seen some software that
does really dumb stuff with regard to
fees I haven't seen that that would be a
new thing so I don't think so what the
current Bitcoin D algorithm does even
that can get me off sometimes and it
allows sort of a estimate okay how how
quickly do you need this do you need
this in the next hour do you need in the
next six hours the next half hour
so yeah the one in Bitcoin D is better
but it's it's it's not it's like it's
easy to say oh this should be easy
the thing is it's a weird market you
you're bidding for something that you
don't quite know and you don't know what
other participants are gonna pile it
sometimes so you know something like
this Oh a block didn't come out for half
an hour and a bunch of other people came
and submitted higher bids after you and
so now you got out in practice you well
yeah someone who submitted a bid here
you know transaction here a block came
out there and zoom in for example it's
too low but you know I I submitted
something here I think it'll get in but
then all these other people came after
me and then the block didn't confirm
mine it did later right another few
minutes later but it's hard you know
there's never any determinism and how
it's gonna work right because it's all
over the world they are they do tend to
be lower on the weekends people don't
make as many transactions on the
weekends and so yeah sometimes people
sometimes people will say hey I've got
these transactions in practice if you
say I don't care how long it takes just
set a low fee and wait
and and it'll stay in the mempool for
weeks and then can be you know so there
have been people who said I made a
transaction I put a super low fee it
confirmed a month later the thing is if
you should go yeah this is something of
a transient but if you look over six
months it's really highly variable like
it used to be sort of nothing and then I
it's part of it is the it looks it looks
most dramatic here because you're
sorting life yeah let's Joseph you right
it's like nothing deal with it and then
like whoa okay and this people were
complaining hey it's days where nothing
confirmed here was weeks months like all
of December and January and that was it
was too correlated with everyone in the
media everyone wanting to buy bitcoins
the price skyrocketed so it's very sort
of peaky and then I think interest has
died down a bit and the fees have gone
down with it so this is a hard market to
deal with this is this is a hard problem
to deal with and it wasn't something
people were dealing with until a few
months ago most of the time you can get
by with just setting a low you know
fixed fee or something and it would work
but now we're really seeing the free
market develop also people disagreed
that this should even be a thing so if
you're you know there's Bitcoin cash
there's all these Forks you know the
idea of if you start hitting the block
size limit increase the limit why should
we have to pay fees the miners are
already getting plenty of money to mind
with we should just have as much
transactions than we want so there's
people to say that okay yes
if you're not getting huge issue fees
that's what I'm gonna get to next yeah
so not always like so one your software
might not do that most software it you
know in the last few years just said
look once once the transactions sent
it's stuck
right just like yeah I sent it waiting
for it to confirm and you have to
actually code something to deal with
changing the transaction ID invalidating
old one you know that's some software so
one way I saw one way a wallet could
deal with this and say okay well I'll do
child pays for parent this is actually a
little bit easier software wise you know
to invalidate anything you say I'm gonna
send a transaction spending one of those
new outputs that's not confirmed with a
very high fee now the average of the two
will be high enough maybe it'll get in
you can also do this when you're on the
receiving end right so someone sent you
a coin but they sent a low it was sent
that transaction below fee and maybe you
can't contact them anymore maybe they're
unresponsive or they don't care and
you're like well I really need to you
know I need this money
I want it confirmed I can then re spend
that output with a high fee to convert
both of them it's kind of annoying but
possible downsides of this child pays
for parent is very inefficient right
you're making an extra transaction and
it's exacerbating the problem you're
trying to solve right the whole problem
is there's too many transactions there's
not enough space and you're you know
increasing your priority in the queue by
wasting even more space so if everyone
does child phase for parent it's it's
sort of really bad now every transaction
is gonna take two or three transactions
and the dependency graphs are kind of
complex you can have I don't want to I
don't remember exactly how there are
certain cases where child pays for
parent lowers the priority of a
transaction I didn't understand how but
there was someone explained it to me and
I'm like oh shoot that's bad where
someone else spending an output can that
like if there's like a whole branch of
tons of different outputs and tons of
different tile child papers when there
are certain clerks where okay if someone
makes a low fee transaction that can
actually
lower the priority of the parents I
don't remember how anyway so it's kind
of a mess it's complex and it's also
just very inefficient okay so another
way which seems obvious why don't I just
double spend it I made a transaction
with the low fee why doesn't my wallet
just say look I'm gonna replace that
transaction with one with a higher fee
and I just decorate you know I decrease
the change output amount that's simple
right no problem
the default relay behavior is to ignore
double spends and this is not just a
default that's for fun this is actually
there's good reasons for it so if you
see a transaction spending output a
output B and then you see another
transaction over the wire spending one
of those outputs that you've already
seen you will ignore it
you won't ban that you won't get mad at
the person who sent it to you but you'll
just ignore it if you like no I already
saw a conflicting transaction so the
default is first thing you see is the
thing you go with this is not a
consensus rule right because we're not
dealing with anything that's in the
blocks yet but any ideas of why this is
an important rule to have what are some
attacks that you could perform if you
just said yeah anything you know I'm not
gonna stick with the first seen
transaction I will update anytime I see
a new one I'll just go with the elbow
with the last seen transaction instead
of first seen transaction what would be
an attack that would be enabled by that
the ID is you gotta think adversarially
I'm trying to bring down Bitcoin if you
change your code to you know last scene
instead of first scene how do I bring
down the network yeah I just keep
spending the same outputs a hundred
times a second and you know they all
have the same fee rate I can just keep
doing that indefinitely and I just keep
flooding the network and everyone's like
oh here's the student oh here's this uh
uh you know total mess however there is
a way to prevent that kind of flooding
attack or at least you know
significantly mitigate it which is
okay we'll relay conflicting
transactions but we require an increase
in the fee and the required increase is
equal to our minimum relay fee of one
Satoshi per bite right so every time I
could say okay I'm going to replace it
because it has higher fee so now it's
sort of constantly incrementing you
can't keep doing that indefinitely every
time you want to you want to send a
transaction out to the network and use
everyone's network resources you are
sort of potentially paying something for
ya you will you will continue to ignore
transactions with same or lower fee oh I
did the why yeah the why happened better
anyway yeah the DOS attack is make lakhs
of transactions the same thing okay so
this seems simple right
we have replaced by fee if you have a
higher transaction fee you replace the
transactions waltz implement it no
problem no well people don't like it
people said no we don't like for place
by fee this was a controversy around
2015 when a bunch of the developers were
like you know this seems reasonable
let's put it in people said no this
hurts the security of unconfirmed
transactions and to some extent they do
have a point right if if every note on
the network says I'm going with my first
seen transaction right if there's a
conflicting transaction later I ignore
it
that means it's hard to double spend
even before it gets into a block right
you you you spend you say okay I'm gonna
send money to Alice and here's my change
output and then you replace it with I'm
gonna send money to Bob instead it might
change output you can potentially make
it appear that someone's going to get
paid it still says unconfirmed but they
say yeah yeah you're you sent me a
transaction it'll get confirmed soon and
then switch it out and try to you know
make it so that you pay back to yourself
instead when everyone on the network
ignores those new transactions it gets
harder you'd have to contact contact a
minor directly and say hey I have this
transaction on the network here's a
conflicting one please include it in
your next block and then you know to
double spend to defraud this person the
thing is in practice it's not that hard
to do this and so a lot of the
developers look
confirmed transactions really have no
security with them and and yeah it might
seem like we're reducing the security
here but you really should not depend on
unconfirmed at all it's not in the
blockchain there's no proof of work the
whole point of this system is to put the
proof of work to really get consensus
and you cannot rely on network level
consensus because there isn't any and
yeah so to some extent it does replace
by feet does make the double spins
easier to do that's the point but the
thing is it's it's not secure anyway so
anyway it's also you I issued should you
even show unconfirmed transactions
almost all of the wallets do even the
SPV once and the SPV ones have no idea
if it's even valid or has a valid
signature since they can't even check
signatures right unconfirmed
transactions don't are not meaningless
if you see it on the network and you're
running a full node you see yes this is
a transaction that could be confirmed
right they've provided a valid signature
any miner can put this in there's no
conflicts you know this can work if your
SPV and you see an unconfirmed
transaction you have no idea right
because you can't you don't even know if
it's pending outputs that exists because
you don't have a you TXO set you can't
verify the signatures you don't even
know what the keys are supposed to be
but most SPV wallets still show
unconfirmed transactions because users
want it they want to know and it's like
sometimes they'll put it in like red
text like hey it's unconfirmed or put a
little question mark next to it I would
rather just not show it at all I think
it's you know gives a misleading sense
to users but this is this is an issue
right users like oh I want to know if
it's you know if the person if the
sender has actually signed and sent and
then you know afterwards it gets in the
block yeah now it's confirmed now it's
safe but I want to know so I guess we
can sometimes connect to multiple no
it's an ask but this is this is a
controversial thing that people have
argued about my personal opinion is that
like you know security sort of is more
important than you UI and usability in
this case and you really should not rely
on anything that has unconfirmed
transactions and also the RBF the
replaced by feed policy is not a network
you know consensus level rule
you don't know what policy people have
if Paula if people are running you know
if nodes are running I just stick with
the first scene transaction or I replace
with incrementing fees or I replace no
matter what or who know I'll you know
I'll go with three or four updates and
then I'll stop email then I'll ignore
you just don't know what people are
doing so the compromise that's currently
in the the default the Bitcoin software
is called opt in replaced by fee you
flag a transaction by changing the the
sequence number in the input to not be
ffffff
and then you indicate hey I'm I'm
flagging my transaction as this can be
replaced with an increase increasing fee
it's kind of ugly in my opinion it's
like wow it's not really opt-in you
can't even opt out it's it's weird to
say to people like oh yeah you opt into
RBF because there's no way to prevent it
you can always contact the miners or
anyone can just run it and there's
there's code out there that's a couple
lines different that's like here's the
full RBF version of Bitcoin where it'll
just you know ignore this flag and treat
everything the same but we do now have
the option so if you if you're on a
wallet and I believe that the Bitcoin
core wallet it with a new version last
week or last month now by default Flags
every transaction as replaced by fee so
that you can then bump the fee later on
yeah and this is a much better way to
deal with fees because then you're not
stuck and then to some extent you don't
even need to look at the mem pool and
what these other everyone else is paying
you can just say well I I can also time
lock transactions and I can say okay
well at the current block
I'll pay one Satoshi per byte I'll also
send out a transaction where it's not
valid until the next block and I paid
two Satoshi she's provide and then the
block after that I'll pay for and then
block after that I'll pay eight or
whatever sort of schedule you know fee
schedule you want and then the miners
now have the option to look and say well
two situations per byte is too little
I'm not going to take it but and then
the block comes out okay now it's four
okay I'll take that one and so that's a
really nice sort of fire-and-forget
from the users wallet where I don't know
I don't even know what fee I should pay
well look I'll just keep incrementing it
and hopefully it confirms soon it'll owe
rate as it takes longer and longer the
my rate goes up and eventually I'll get
it in yeah not really okay so one limit
is you cannot actually broadcast the
transaction that is valid in a future
block people ignore you know the network
will ignore it similar reason you know
denial of service thing where hey here's
the transactions that's valid next week
well why'd you tell it to me today so
you'd have to be online to do that but
your your wallet can do it automatically
right you can just do in the background
and in practice I don't know any wallets
that do that right now the core wallet
will allow you to in the UI you sort of
right-click and you say you know bump
increase fee and then it'll you know
rebroadcast with an increased fee okay
so yeah it's it's a kind of a mess but
it's getting there we're getting better
at this any questions before we have a
break will they eventually with a
complete well yeah so some some you know
some sites will accept zero calm without
RBF but not with my thinking is they
shouldn't be accepting zero confirmation
transactions regardless so whatever but
yeah and people there was a thing what
Peter Todd like stole $10 from coinbase
like a couple years ago because he was
sort of trying to prove a point and it's
so easy to double spend before it's in a
block and all these different sites are
saying oh yeah here's the transaction
it's not confirmed yet but it will be
soon
and then they dispense with the product
and then I remember Peter Todd was like
look I just got 10 bucks from you on
like Steam or whatever do you want it
back and they didn't
why because it's really not that hard to
double spend before it's Anna block the
whole point of the blockchain all the
mining is to prevent the double span
right okay so the last part is gonna be
about oh yeah I already said this yeah
one thing though is further research is
needed this has all been changing in the
last year if you had this talk a year
ago it would sort of be like yeah I
guess you can do replace wifey I guess
fees could work this way but we had
never really had this sustained long fee
ramped up like you know we had this
hadn't happened right this it never
happened there had been cases where like
sometimes walks had been full but you
never seen this ramped up it's also
really interesting how inelastic it was
in that people started paying you know
six you know thousands of satoshis per
byte $20 $30 a transaction and people
got mad about it but what was
interesting is people were paying right
if everyone if everyone refuses to pay
these rates the rates go down but
someone's paying that much but a lot of
it is exchanges and stuff so okay yeah
problems exchange is over pay Bitcoin to
you wallets over pace nobody hear it for
seven years it's sort of like it's also
efficiency wise in terms of your
transaction size kinda reminds me of
like 2008 when like everyone's driving
Hummers and then gas goes to like four
bucks and then everyone gets the price
that's happening now where it's like
okay let's batch our transactions let's
use compressed pub keys you know there's
all sorts of techniques to reduce the
size of your transactions some more can
fit in the block
which are now still being implemented
it's sort of after the fact you know it
takes it takes this hey your loot you
know you're spending thousands of
dollars a day on this to you know really
kick people into actions it to write it
I remember looking into the December
though at clean bases transactions and
being like you should hire you you guys
are probably losing a million dollars a
day I could fix this for you you should
but it's sort of frustrating to see and
probably their systems like a huge mess
from like so many different layers and
things on top of each other that it's
hard to fix but looking at you know
Gemini also is an exchange they use
uncompressed pub keys so the pub keys
are 65 bytes instead of 33 there's no
advantage there it's just an extra 32
bytes which they've probably spent I
don't know a couple hundred K on just
that weird aspect of their software I
don't know if they're aware of this even
might want to be like hey guys you're
spending too much money because look
your transactions are an extra 32 bytes
per input and because of this but yeah
it's it's fairly it's it's interesting
to see I've also paid you know I used to
not pay oh one thing that used to be the
case transactions had priority which was
based on the age of the outputs
multiplied by the amount of the outputs
that was a thing until two years ago and
was great because it meant if you were
rich you didn't pay fees so if you had a
bunch of Bitcoin it was you know kind of
a maybe not so great social idea that
like hey if you have an output that's
got 100 coins in it you can make a fee
with no transaction you know you can
make it zero fee transaction it actually
worked from a theoretical perspective
because it prevented spam because the
idea is if you have a hundred coins okay
you can you can spend that you know
every day or something with no fee if
you have only one coin maybe you have to
wait a hundred days to be able to spend
it with no fee so there's this sort of
priority age based - you know limit the
the you know velocity of these payments
based on how big their they got rid of
that because it made sense from a
network level let's protect the network
from spam idea it did not make any sense
for the miners to prioritize these
transactions right why you know I'm a
miner who cares if you have a bunch of
old outputs that you haven't spent in a
long time does nothing for me
right it does help the network in
general but so I was a little
disappointed because I don't have a ton
of coins but they're all really old so I
could get away with not paying fees ok
yeah long term though this is sort of an
inch
take a look at I'm not sure that's I
I'll shoot is that number right wait
James do you know is it two hundred ten
thousand I think it is that one we're
number arrived you might be wrong I've
made a mental note to confirm it but I
think it's right anyway
the mining reward drops in half every
four years approximately and eventually
all the coins are mined so it's it's
dropped in half twice right first it was
50 coins a block then 25 and I was 12
and a half in a two years it's gonna be
six point two five or something so
eventually all the coins are gone you
mind them all that takes a hundred years
so everyone's like yeah I'll be dead you
know I'll be gone you'll be gone but
actually the rewards become negligible a
lot sooner than you think in twenty
years there's you know way less than a
coin in rewards right because it keeps
you know keeps getting chopped in half
every four years so yeah there's this
sort of long tail where we've got like
fifty years of like a couple satoshis
per block but it's it's negligible right
so the rewards be you know going to near
zero actually happens you know
definitely within our lifetimes pretty
soon and a lot of people looking at
Bitcoin are sort of thinking of it long
term it only makes sense bitcoins only
worth a lot of money now because people
think it's gonna be worth a lot of money
in twenty years right if everyone knew
it was gonna collapse in ten years I
think people would lose interest so what
are some weird long-term problems okay
well if there's no new coins to mine why
do you mind well the title of this okay
these yeah however it's not that simple
there's a lot of problems with the fees
only being the only incentive in that TX
fees are very variable without a backlog
the fees tend to go to pretty close to
zero and if the fees are zero there's no
reason to mind right all the new coins
have been generated there's no fees in
the mempool why am i running my you know
if you've got if maybe I have a megabyte
worth of zero feed transactions in the
mempool but as a miner why am i spending
electricity to mine this I get nothing
so the miners just turned off right that
would be what they should do and you can
see yeah it's super variable
maybe miners are like oh this is great
we're making ton of money and then here
they're like oh yes you know wrap it up
close down the mining facility and that
can be a problem even on much shorter
time skills such as the timescale of a
single block so for example here's what
you do your miner there's no fees in the
mempool there's no reward there's no
reason to mine right turn off your chips
and then turn them back on once the
mempool starts flowing filling up
because it will eventually the idea is
okay for the next couple minutes I'm
just idling you could do that or you
could be clever and say well I've got
all these chips you know the opportunity
cost you know a lot of it is capex a lot
of is the capital expense of the chips
and not the electricity so if I'm just
turning off my chips that's a huge loss
for me I want to run I don't want to run
with an empty mmm pool because I get
nothing what should I do
what's a fun attack yeah very good idea
I'm pretty sure binders are doing this
or were in November that doesn't help
you that that helps you sort of medium
term right in the very short term where
there's no empty mempool what do I do
there is another attack you can do yeah
I don't get any money so you could but
that's not a fun attack yeah
yeah but I want to get money I want like
I want to get paid there's nothing in
the Med pool where do I go okay so yes
so so in bitcoins case the algorithm
well now there's pickle in cash and so
there's sort of two chains that that
share a single algorithm and in many alt
coins they share either algorithms or
they're using a GPU which can be you
know quickly switched between different
mining algorithms in bitcoins case
though you're sort of stuck right it's a
it's a big one and you're using shot to
v6 so eh okay yeah yeah you go back to
the past you mind the past transactions
right okay someone mind a bunch of
transactions here and they got two
bitcoins those are two bitcoins I could
have mined right so that last block had
a couple coins in fees I'm gonna remind
it I'm not getting anything if I mind if
I if I continue the chain and make
progress I get no money but if I try to
snipe the last guys mining stuff I might
be able to take take his money
if you find two blocks in a row which
happens you get all the fees so that's
sort of an optimal thing to do like I've
got all this mining power yeah maybe I
turn it off because I'm mostly op X
instead of capex but if I've got all
this mining power I mean you use it no
matter what
well the the optimal thing to do is try
to take you know reorg the blockchain
and take the last person's fees so for
example so yeah instead of sequentially
building you fight over it so here's
this blockchain okay Alice got to I've
got three Carol got two Dave got one
these are fees within the block right
and now the current man pool it's zero
they've got it they've swept it you know
there was it was sort of declining sort
of going up Dave you know completely
emptied the men pool there's nothing in
there and there's no new coins coming
out so I'm what Eve I'm the attacker he
was always the bad person right so I
what's also even better I say okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna build I'm gonna try to
reorder I can take all the fees here I
can take the two bitcoins here and the
one bit
here and I can mine it into this block
this block is not valid yet right this
is higher but I might build another
block here and I might build another
block here and by now there might be
some coins so now I get four coins
I could have mined here and got nothing
if this happens and I pull it off - okay
Carol and Dave's coins are now mine so
this is a and to some extent you might
think well whatever it's a little messy
but this is not the worst thing in the
world
you still make progress it's actually
really bad because you're now trading
this sort of memoryless process where
everyone's competing on a level playing
ground for whoever can mine fastest is
always going to win here right so you
know you're you know if you're a miner
that's twice as big as the next guy
you're always gonna be able to do this
not always right there's there's still
some but but as this this really reduces
the variance and really incentivizes the
miners to consolidate and you're going
to end up with a monopoly in this kind
of a scenario because small players will
just always get reorg down yeah so the
question is this an attack seems like
they're just trying to get paid right
like you you're not you're not trusting
the money the whole idea is you're not
trusting the miners you're just assuming
that they're acting in their economic
interests to some extent you could say
well if they keep doing this they've
reduced the utility of Bitcoin and so
it's bad for their holdings yeah maybe
but it's it's it looks dangerous right
however this isn't a problem we don't
see this problem today there's there
have actually been several cases where
we should have where it would have been
optimal for the miners so someone made a
fee that was like thousand big you know
was like four hundred bitcoins or
something they were just like screwed up
they made a transaction and the you know
they were spending like a thousand
bitcoins and they only sent like six
hundred out or something
so the feat was four hundred bitcoins
which is like hey that's way more than a
block that's millions of dollar it
wasn't when it was millions of dollars
but it's still a ton of money and the
miners if they were rational they should
have all just stopped and all tried to
fight each other over that one block
right in that one transaction because
it's so much more valuable than like
progressing the chain
however they didn't because they were
just running their software they didn't
you know they didn't they weren't
anticipating this kind of thing
however this becomes if this becomes
long term the the general state of the
network they'll definitely anticipate it
and they'll write the software to do
this so it's not a problem when there's
low reward variants from block to block
if every block you know if you're the
next block coming out has about the same
fees as the last one then you just keep
building on it and you're not trying to
like snipe other people in the past but
that means there's gonna be a backlog
right you need this really big mempool
with a large backlog of transactions to
ensure that you have low variance in the
rewards and to ensure that long term
you've got a stable system so this is
tricky this is a hard problem because
you've already got these sort of
scalability balances in Bitcoin one of
them is related to your hardware right
so if you say ok we'll gonna we're gonna
make the block size really small we're
gonna make the block size 10 kilobytes
so you can only have a few transactions
every 10 minutes if it's too small then
very few people can actually use Bitcoin
right but there's just not that many
transactions a second most people will
have something like coinbase where
someone else holds the coins for them
that's no fun the point is to have your
own UTX OS and really be in control of
your own money and have your own private
keys right however if the blocks are too
large then not many people can run it if
the blocks are a gigabyte each and
you've got these you know petabyte sized
block chains I can't run that I need a
data center and then you can't really
verify and validate that the system is
operating the way you think it will
you're just gonna have to trust again
some kind of big institution to do it
for you
so they both sort of turn into the same
thing when you're at the extremes right
if it's too small well I can't really
own my own coins I gotta have someone
else do it for me if it's too large I
guess I can own my own private keys but
I have no idea if they're actually you
know if there's an actual transaction in
the blockchain because I can't download
it so these are sort of balances based
on hardware and we're thinking well as
computer gets as computers get more
powerful and networks get more powerful
we can sort of
into the larger side and people will
still be able to run it and and we have
seen that so like with a seg wit the
block size has been increased through a
soft work so it now takes a bit more
space and more network traffic to use
however the long term fee sniping thing
it's not Hardware related right even if
you had perfect computers that we're
sort of like oh this network can send
any amount of data instantly
we've got unlimited harddrive space you
know these are you know computronium
that's a thing right theoretical maximum
computer so even if you have like this
amazing computer and the hardware limits
are not a limit at all you still have to
balance the block size because if you
make your block size too large you're
going to have that problem on term where
there's no real fee market because
there's no competition to get into the
blocks and so the whole system's kinds
of halts and then you've got the largest
miners keep winning so this is visible
there's a paper what's it called Bitcoin
[Music]
like Bitcoin is not stable without a fee
or something I mean I can it's a
Princeton guys right
Bitcoin on the instability of Bitcoin
without the block reward and like to be
fair yeah these are Princeton guys yeah
the to be fair they write about how they
write about this issue but it's a little
weird because one of their assumptions
is that mining strategy simulator anyway
one of their assumptions is that every
miner completely wipes out the mempool
at every block and it's like wait that
that assumption given that assumption
yes you can show that it's unstable and
there's all these problems like I was
showing but that assumption is a huge
assumption and we a lot of the people
working on Bitcoin you're like no you
can't make that assumption we because
we're aware that there's these
instability problems and the solution so
the extent that it's the solution is
always have a backlog always have you
know there's there's a really big demand
for transactions and there's not enough
space and so people have to compete
based on their fees in that case you can
have a stable system long term where the
miners get paid but without it these
guys show it and so yeah they're there
you know it's true but it's sort of
weird because one of their assumptions
is that there are no fees long term
essentially so yeah so this is this is a
weird issue and it's also sort of how
timing wise do we need to worry about
this now maybe we can just punt the
problem for a decade and try to get lots
of adoption and lots of people using
Bitcoin and we'll figure it out once
it's really well-established I don't
think that works I think it's harder and
harder to change these systems as more
people use it so maybe we're stuck and
it's almost certain that like one
megabyte or four megabytes is not the
optimal size we have no idea what the
optimal size is right the long term
because it's also long term how many
people are gonna be using this and for
what and for what kind of transactions
so it's it's a definitely an open
problem yeah so we're sort of at the
dawn of the fees we're you know a year
ago we didn't have all these things
we're starting to understand the fee
markets and see how it works what's
interesting is that the elasticity seems
like people really want their
transactions in when they want them in
which I guess can make sense if you're
you know the price of Bitcoin spikes to
$18,000 you're like I want to sell one
it's gonna crash and you're like yeah
I'll pay 50 bucks to move it to sell to
someone because I'm selling millions of
dollars worth and so there's it seems
really inelastic you also have people
companies wasting millions of dollars on
fees that you can just be like why why
did you do okay you know you're what
you're wasting on space wasting on fees
it is a fun research area and it's
definitely research and so I'm like yeah
I hope this works like we don't really
know a long term if this whole system is
stable and works I think you can but you
know it's not it's not like something to
base the global economy on just yet
because we're not quite sure it all
really works long term but we think it
does okay any questions about this sort
of long-range attack stuff don't have
fees or the fees are enforced you can
enforce a fee you can say hey the
consensus rule of this system is that
every transaction has to have a 50
satoshis per bite fee there's problems
with that because then you can have
out-of-band fees where if you try to
make it a consensus rule it doesn't
really work because it's sort of like
price controls where you can say hey you
have to sell you know milk for two
dollars a gallon and it's like well
that's not what the market says so
people can go out of band and then
they're saying okay the consensus rule
is I have to pay this fee but really how
about you give me some of it back or so
so generally the rules they put in an
hour minimum fees which you can try to
work around that way but in general most
of the other altcoins
with the exception of aetherium the
theorem definitely has similar issues
but most of the all coins have a block
size or a network capacity that exceeds
their uses so there aren't really there
isn't really competition to get into the
next block aetherium though similar to
Bitcoin
has well I don't yeah
where did it go this kind of thing I
don't know if you graphed aetherium
probably wouldn't look quite the same
but there there are also times in
aetherium where the fees skyrocket a lot
of times with like I cos everyone wants
to get in their bids really quick and so
they'll you know the network will get
super congested for a day and no one can
use it for anything for normal uses so
aetherium also has this problem it's not
quite the same in that it's not a block
size it's a gas per block kind of thing
so how much computation or storage it's
using but in practice it's it's a
similar thing so yeah those are sort of
the only two that I'm aware of that
really have hit this issue so far any
other questions about this yes
should I take advice from counsel before
commenting on this yeah so you you could
Google there's one I don't know if
you're talking about specifically
there's one called iota that we looked
at last summer I don't have you know my
mom tells me when if you don't have
anything nice to say don't say anything
but we did say it's quite a bit in our
in our you know report I I don't that
one specifically I don't think it really
works that well actually they have a fee
they they just pretend they don't but
they very much have a fee so in the an
iris case they say you have to do work
on your transaction right you have to
mine your transaction and they say
that's not a fee well okay it's not a
fee or paying to some other minor but
you're still doing work right that has a
cost you could say it's a cost not a fee
I don't know
but it's sort it feels like saying hey
this this refrigerator doesn't need
electricity to run it's got a hand crank
in the bank back that you have to you
know yeah okay I don't to plug it in but
I have to do that like I still have to
do all the work so so it's it's an
anti-spam measure which is you know you
have to do work on so same you think
thing but there are some that you know
have no fee whatsoever and they're very
susceptible to spamming right if there's
no fee what stops me from just sending
out a bazillion transactions and having
everyone else store them
you don't need global consensus and so
you do need global consensus from state
anyway but since there are movies yeah
there's a lot of I I'm I'm there's a lot
of really smart people you know way
smarter than me working on these things
and and it's a hard problem and they
seem to think it's a hard problem so I'm
very skeptical when someone especially
with a financial interest in getting me
to believe that they've solved this
problem says hey I've solved the problem
zero fees infinite scalability I'm just
very skeptical when I see that because
ok what you do like we've been looking
at this maybe maybe there's you know
maybe there's something there
but um I haven't seen any really great
stuff you know there's Lightning Network
which I'll talk about in a few weeks and
I think that's pretty cool and I sort of
work on that there's other different you
know ways to do this but the you know
the in general there's got to be a cost
right there's no free lunch and you're
gonna have to if you're requiring other
people to store a lot of data and
process it there's got to be some kind
of limit there
you